[Music]
welcome to ear biscuits I'm link and I'm
Rhett this week at the round table of
dim lighting we are asking the question
should you switch which side of the bed
you sleep on oh man another question I'm
good
I got a shiver down my spine when I
heard you ask that and when I
immediately read it I was like I feel
threatened this is a question from a
mythical beast in response to a prompt
that we put out on I don't know where do
we put it out Twitter Facebook how do we
do Twitter I've got a lot of really good
questions follow us on facebook follow
us on Instagram
follow us on follow us everywhere follow
us follow us to the ends of the earth
don't think just follow so yeah I'm
excited about that question and and a
number of questions that that we got so
excited that we should just get right
into one of the questions yeah let's do
it you feeling excited well I am you
don't look excited well because I like
to ease into the day you know people who
start early still to come in and seem
too excited for the morning they burn
out so fast I build about you thinking
about somebody in particular no I would
say that one out of eight days you do
that and I could kind of see it in your
face it's kind of like I got a psych
myself up I got to psych myself up man
and you come in and you're talking
yourself up and I could tell that you
have not had a good day so far so no no
no my theory about you is that when you
seem excited it's because I'm kind of
compensate it isn't because old links
having a great time he's super excited
he's in a great mood when you're having
a good day I think you're like this yeah
i flatly right but if I'm not having a
good day I seem like I'm having a great
day yeah and if I seem like I'm having a
great day so I am having a great day I
don't psych myself up that never happens
right right no I'm one out of every
eight days I need to have a good day I
work my way into a good day every day I
like to have something to look forward
to not something to dwindle you know
what I'm saying so set your expectations
low the beginning of the day don't smile
too much don't seem too excited listen
by the end of the day you'll be happy
there's another thing so sometimes
you're right okay I'm not gonna say
you're wrong
often I'm right about this 75% of the
time all right Syd I'm not talking about
its general yeah I'm talking about
oh yeah 75% of the time you're right
about my one in eight times I'm acting
happy when I'm not in order to see
become happy okay good but there are
times when you're just happy when I'm
just freaking happy in the morning like
and it it usually has to do with some
magical song came in on my playlist on
my drive in oh you're - yeah yeah that's
that's a problem no why is it gonna be a
problem
no I'm saying this be happy for here's
what I'll say oh don't get happy because
of music if no music can make you happy
but if you know that music can change
your mood you should find the songs that
do that and you should make sure that
one of those is always in the playlist
no I don't want you to be happy like 1
out of 8 times I want you to be happy
like all the time if it's a possibility
now you're sounding like an addict
here's the thing are you addicted to
music happiness is not something you can
manufacture my brother it's something
that and when you do it diminishes but
when a song it's kind of like when your
favorite song comes on the radio it
makes you happier then when it comes on
when you select your scroll and select
it you're not listening to the radio
though I'm not but I'm listening to
Spotify curated playlists that they like
the algorithm thinks I like so when
you're lying on the computer to make you
happy yeah when the computer problem
when I make myself at but I'm in control
listen I'm not interested in happiness
I'm interested in joy fine everything I
was saying I was talking about joy Joey
really syllables Joey Joey Joey no
you're in the South when you don't know
whether someone is asking for joy or
Joey Joey did you say joy or Joey
because I couldn't tell do we want to
start with the bed
question oh oh you getting happy too
soon I'm letting natural circumstances
much like a playlist make me happy okay
I'm super excited about this question
because we didn't talk about this far
now we didn't talk about this because of
the way that the vacations worked in all
this but I really wanted to know your
opinion on this on this question I've
talked about would this work about my
wife because there was something related
to this that went viral on Twitter so
this is question read the question is
from Mike dadbod Florida that's a good
name my wife out of nowhere eight years
into our marriage decided she wanted to
change what side of the bed we sleep on
now especially in the context of the
question my wife eight years in Tamera's
decided she wanted to change what side
of the bed she want to sleep on it she
sent shivers down my spine I can only
imagine like I just felt I had a fear
reaction of empathy to you dad bod
Florida now that dad bods
all of a sudden find himself on the
other side of the bed I think what I'm
about to tell you don't want to have a
knee-jerk emotional blow your mind I
want to analyze this and I want to be
open to well and I have it I have a
theory about the way that you approach
this and I think you probably have a
theory about the way I would approach
this now the reason this I wanted to get
into this question is because a few
weeks ago on Twitter there was a guy who
said a girl I don't know who exactly it
was it was someone I don't think they
were a public personality and maybe they
were anyway they were like last night we
were hanging out with a couple that
we've been friends with for a while and
we found out that they do not have sides
of the bed that they sleep on Wow
any given night they may end up on
either side of the bed and it's not a
discussion and it just is the way
they've always been in a boy scout drunk
every night and this of course sent
shockwaves throughout the internet
because this is crazy okay I mean I
personally think that and I'm a person
that I don't I'm not routine oriented
yeah but this struck me why as bonkers
you know yeah
the idea that you don't have a side of
the bed because there's just so many
just utilitarian things that go along
with what side of the but you've you've
got bedside tables that have your stuff
in them right you put your phone
hey there's just Reese right there's
reasons to be on the side of the bed
right now and so I I you saying this
called it brings a lot more power than
me saying it because everyone's gonna
know that I'm gonna say my thing but no
but but let me just say your opinion
about that is not a novel opinion that's
a normal opinion that someone would have
a bedside table that has like there's a
drawer that is I'm not even an organized
person but I'm an organized person
compared to my wife at least when you're
talking about drawers so like I got
things in my drawer I got books on my
side I got think the way I want to
charge my phone etc on my side now the
thing that I discovered when Jesse and I
started talking about this and this is
my question for you is have you always
had a particular side of the bed
throughout your whole marriage
regardless of what house you're in and
when you stay in a hotel do you occupy
the same side of the bed that you do at
home that's my question for you and I am
and let me just say that my guess is
that you've always had the same side of
the bed and you always assume it on
vacation maybe I'm wrong maybe I'm
presumptuous but that's my theory I'm
thinking back to all my beds okay
yes I've always throughout 19 years of
marriage I'm sleeping in the same bed
for 19 years
slept on what I'll call the left side so
from my perspective sleeping in the bed
looking up at the ceiling my left
shoulder is closest to the is on the
left side of it so the right I think
most people that your [ __ ] you're
sitting there you're laid you're looking
at a bed and there's a right and a left
sound of like stage left I think like if
you're about to get in the bed I'm like
I'm when I get into bed I'm a performer
brother so I'm talking bad left okay
it's a bed left and I would say room
right room right so
you're looking at the bed in your lamb
I'm gonna sleep on the left side of the
pit or the right side of it you sleep on
the right sleep on the right side and it
magically becomes the left side okay
that's a bonus okay
and this isn't this is just something to
just happen early on in your marriage
and then there was no reason to switch
it I didn't think about it and the
second part of your question when I go
to a hotel room and I'm traveling with
Christy I do I have actively thought
about this we have not discussed it but
like when you walk in the room and
you've got your luggage and I
immediately like to settle in I like to
put the luggage I like to if anything
needs to be hung I like to hang it I
like to put the toiletries by this by
the sink I like to settle in I like to
feel a secure yeah but that involves
going ahead and kind of claiming a side
of the bed immediately and I don't want
to burden Christy with this conversation
of course the flip side of that is you
should consult your wife she has but we
instinctively knows that we instinctive
things are dead end we we go to this we
go to the same sides and by the way
whenever I'm traveling alone it well you
know what it's up for grabs at that
point but I do sleep on a side of the
bed all right no I think aside that you
determined to be most useful like oh
this better a lamp on this side or
something we got to reach your phone it
was a reason got to reach your phone it
really has to do with like if there's a
plug on one side and I can get to charge
my phone sometimes they're not on both
sides good well I will say that when I
when I sleep in a hotel bed by myself I
sleep in the middle of the bed because
as a big man you can reach anywhere this
is this is like what I always want is a
large bed that I can just go anywhere
and if you're in the middle you can
reach both bedside tables simultaneous I
can put my hands on both tables at the
same time finally you got something to
live for now Jesse and I began to talk
about this and it led to an argument oh
yeah because based on the tweets yeah
because now first of all we sleep just
to give you a lay of the land
I started thinking back through previous
houses and in my previous home I slept
on the other side of the bed
and then and then I went back and the
other and the other house I slept on the
same side that I sleep on now
and so there's seems to be no rhyme or
reason to which side I pick in a
particular house that we're in however
we stay on the side of the bed when we
go on vacation there is no conversation
about it and we end up on either side of
the bed and we never talking about it
just random if you're in a hotel well
sorry it's not random it could be either
side but when I started evaluating the
psychology realizing that I was the one
making the choice first this is when she
got mad you pointed it out I have a
reaiiy have a thought process that's
almost subconscious that has been
determining which side of the bed I
sleep on in every environment that I've
ever slept on a bed okay and what is it
it is I want to be farthest from the
door the door oh you want to put you
want to you want to use your wife as a
human shield
so which that's hence the argument so
what I told her is without even thinking
about it and it's not in and this is why
she's met it's not in relation to her
it's not like I want her to protect me
it's that I have this instinctive and I
don't I've never been a dick I've never
been in a room and had somebody come in
and attack me it's me it's never
happened 41 years right but I am a I'm a
cautious person like I am I am the kind
of person that goes into a public
situation and thinks about where I'm
sitting in a restaurant that kind of
thing I'm not like I'm not a big worrier
in that regard and I don't seem anxious
about it but I feel like almost in like
a pseudo tactical war I'm kind of making
to sit not that I would be capable of
doing anything given the extra couple of
seconds I've only ever been in two
fights and they both ended with me
punching someone in the stomach you know
what I'm saying I'm not a hand-to-hand
combat guy I'm a lover not a fighter
well that's why you gotta you got to
have more space to run but there's this
thing that's like I need some time to
think I again I'm not trying to evaluate
because it's
not a conscious process it's always
without fail go to the side of the bed
or the bed and I know if you remember
this like if for a long time when we
travel we would get to one room into
double beds and I would always pick the
one furthest from the from the door now
and I like that because I wanted to be
further away from the AC right so it
worked out without even discussing she's
usually on a window unit and Jessie was
it was understandably mad because she
was like she you know I have a tendency
to be like when we're out in public and
I start walking sometimes I'll just kind
of just walk ahead and just cut because
I'm so I just I am NOT a very thoughtful
people first you walk in ahead and I
walk very fast and she walks slow and
those she thinks she walks a regular
speed and I walk fast I think I walk
fast and she's slow but maybe you walk
too same speed but when you factor in
leg like well we've had a lot of leg
length arguments let's just say that
and she's got unusual shoes a lot of
times you know I don't she's got like
shoes with fish bowls and what does this
have to do with the bed though
it just means that it's consistent with
my tendency to disregard her in her eyes
yes so therefore she don't you're not
protecting me you're putting me in the
way of the potential crazed person who
will come in here and try to kill us
both when you're like somebody could
come through the window exactly yeah but
that's not what you think I'm not
thinking it is what you're now argue and
now well let me say this now that I am
consciously considering this I'm gonna
be closest to the door now because it
isn't doesn't I'm not gonna sleep any
less so as a physical demonstration of
of love and deference you're going to
sleep closer to put myself in harm's way
you're gonna really for my wife know but
isn't that interesting though that I had
subconsciously chosen this side of the
bed I've been interested in it yeah it's
held my interest and then when I think
back about those other of those previous
houses it was like yes I'm always on the
other side of the door it's the door of
this from the door home because in in
your first house back in Fuquay
I thought it had to do it was something
with like when you stood up to get out
of your bed like the roof angle to the
point where you could not stand up in
your own but that would be because
that's a fact that would have been
either side of the bed because he had a
name Frank that was come that side that
time in Fuquay was completely arbitrary
because the house was a the bedroom was
a converted attic and the door was
equidistant from the foot of the the
foot of the bed well what about what
about the one in Sherman Oaks you your
California home where I was furthest
from the door but but the bed was
against the wall
I was against the wall so you had to
climb over Jesse in order to get in the
bed if she got in first and I think it's
because she stayed up later than you
well I think that's we talked about this
and she said well the reason we did it
in that house is because I was getting
up with it with the kids more often than
you were again another point of
disregard lazy husband but I was like
yeah I mean you're just so much better
about getting in and getting out of the
bed you're small it takes me an extra
few seconds you know something could
happen anyway yeah so I'm not gonna go
that's actually the argument that we had
but I have made the decision now that
now that doesn't mean that we're going
to switch places in our current home
because it's pretty established at this
point and I am furthest from the door
see I think the reason why it
III just don't have I don't have the
door thing that you have for me when we
travel and we're sleeping together like
when we're on vacation in those three
different beds that we were seeing it
I'm always on what I'm calling the left
side which is the right side of the bed
because as I'm sleeping she's moving on
my right side she's there's a there's a
beam over there
and if the beans no I'm not used to a
beam on my left side and so that's gonna
give me a bad night's sleep because
subconsciously I'm disoriented so having
a beam on the right side is normal I
would be on the on the on my left side
is discombobulating I don't think it's
that discombobulating but it is and then
you and you you have more room you know
where you have more room some
consciously to role like if I roll this
way I got more room there's gonna be a
person there but I'm not gonna roll them
they'll off the bed and I know that if
I'm no you're not a child you're not a
toddler and you know what as a matter of
fact last night I just remembered I
rolled off the bed I came as close as
you can come to rolling off the bed yeah
that hasn't happened to me in many years
and you know why because on vacation for
over two weeks we had rails we've been
sleeping on king-sized beds I come back
home to my queen-size it's great in it
yeah I felt like I got a California king
my subconscious was on a king-size bed
and we started rolling over and I was
teetering and I woke up yeah you need a
slide you probably should stick to your
to one side of the bed it seems safer so
because to me that's what it all boils
down to so back to my dad bod Florida's
question for me I had a fear reaction
because I'm afraid of rolling off the
bed or at least having compromised sleep
I think that the side that you're used
to someone being on in the bed with you
makes a big difference on your quality
of sleep but I will say this I can't
believe you you know it might make you
it might make a big difference for a
couple of days but I'm saying that I
again we have a slight difference in
philosophy about this I believe in
continually shaking things up you don't
become dependent upon routine right
couldn't become more flexible but in
this particular situation in the context
of a marriage this is in my mind this
could be that your wife wants to mix
things up I mean this is a mild mixing
but if she's like hey we've been
together for eight years what are the
next eight years are gonna be like well
they're gonna be like me being on the
other side of the bed it for one that's
potentially just take it first of all I
think you should ask why you shouldn't
ask us why you should ask her why cuz we
don't know you should find out is there
any underlying reason or is it just like
hey baby I wanted to shake things up or
no actually I wanted to be further away
from the door so you would be the one to
get killed you could lead to our
intruder game it again and that might
lead to some self sacrificial action
like rats doing but you make a good
point with mixin
things up because I am always gonna be a
proponent of mixing things up when it
comes to the bedroom hey now we're onto
something
okay I got your writing so Mike this
could be a things could be getting
exciting this could be this could be
like a little you never know where this
is gonna lead here's what I'll say you
know what go for it I think I want to
just before we move on go down the
waterside I want to acknowledge now that
I think about your which side of the bed
you consider the right and left side of
the bed you might have something here
because when you're in a car the right
side of the car is as reference from
being inside of the car I don't want to
tell you but yeah you're right but I
feel like I'm right when you go no but I
think if you go to a mattress store and
you ask a person selling mattresses
touch the right side of the mattress
what is the person selling the mattress
gonna do I think they're gonna touch the
right side of the mattress as if you're
looking at the bed I agree but it's not
his mattress do you think it changes
once it becomes your mattress or changes
once you get into bed when it becomes
your bed your mattress talk about mixing
things up I mean you've really shaken me
with that I mean I sustained a injuries
from sleeping on the same side of the
bed for too long my show I would sleep
on my right side that was sleeping on
the wrong side of your body I know it's
not the side I would say boon Christie
but I would use my arm I put my right
elbow up next to my right ear and I
would use my own elbow as a pillow and I
did that for so long that like the bones
in my shoulder started to grind against
each other and like wore down the
freaking cushion and now I have
technical term I have pain there and so
I learned to sleep on my back and I
can't spoon anymore but the solution
could be or you wear down the left
shoulder you can spoon I could get to do
good spoon but you can't spoon sleep you
but you can spoon just for fun it still
hurts or I think there's no spooning now
I think I can't I can't
spoon because I think that I'm grinding
my shoulder
so I actually try to keep my elbow down
by my hip and spoon that way well the
thing about me just weird
the thing about spooning me up right but
you're laying down as I've always only
ever been the big spoon because if I'm
the little spoon with Jesse it's like I
have a backpack on you know saying it's
like it's not it's not not the same
sensei you're ultra-large
little spoon shall we move on well I
just want to make sure we've got closure
here we've told him he needs to talk to
his wife about this but fun but then
take it as ironically you know what I'm
gonna do tonight imma get imma imma
getting the bed first I'm gonna get in
on Christie so I'm not gonna say
anything that's not gonna work I'm gonna
go all the way to sleep and see if she
wakes me if you move the furniture at my
work move all the stuff in there yeah I
think I think Christie and I'm all right
I'm all doable here maybe we need to
throw throw it in the mix to like switch
it up yeah see how it feels let's both
let's both do that with our wives in
Mintz and then report back let's sleep
let's talk him in Jessi she won't care
right
mmm I don't know I got to talk to you
about this yeah we can't decide right
now for I can't make I've learned
anything I'm not gonna make a decision
although I guess it affects my wife what
we're gonna we're gonna begin
negotiations which may lead to a trial
period of sleeping on the other side of
the bed and see what happens yeah mix it
up but I guarantee you there'll be some
bad night's sleep now for me no I'm
being honest with you it's I know for a
fact it's not going to affect because I
do it randomly when we travel in it
thanks Mike for so we got more questions
but first we want to let you know that
you can go over to mythical calm and you
can pick up one of these snowed bucks
it's a notebook it's a sketchbook it's
both that's why it's ass note this was
Jenna's I think she's been punished got
written a lot of things got her number
in there get the GMM logo on one email
just in case it's lost
you got the ranlo logo hold it up by
your face so that it can be in the shot
my brother so one of these was designed
by our very own Caitlyn was that this
one he was both of them both of them
that makes it easier she did both okay
you did both of them well artsy mythical
dot-com writing stuff down is powerful
it's good for your brain it's good for
your life experience and I like knowing
that we're a part of that so buy it
here's another question from science is
an art huh I moved in with my boyfriend
a few months ago and he has apparently
never washed a dish or cooked anything
more complicated than ramen in his life
okay apparently spaghetti is too complex
for him so what most basic dish can I
teach him to introduce him to cooking
let me say that last part in a way that
makes more sense
so what basic dish can I teach him to
introduce him to cooking okay well you
know for me I'm not a cooker I'm not a
chef er I'm not a maker of dishes I'm
not proud of that but it's just the what
it's just the fact I'm I'm nothing about
learning how to cook has ever appealed
to me and again I'm just it's almost a
confession but you already knew that I
am however a cleaner so I'm observing
right off the bat so you like the part
that no one does you you you pick the
only thing that nothing part of the
process that nobody likes well the thing
the way that I've always justified it in
like Cristy enjoys cooking sometimes not
all the time but because I don't enjoy
cooking at all if someone's gonna cook
it's on her until now the kids have
gotten old enough to start preparing
things themselves especially Lily who
also enjoys cooking and baking to to a
large extent so I've always felt guilty
that like she's been expected to do the
cooking and not in like a you know a
masculine feminine role type way but
just in a personal taste kind of way
honestly I believe that's why
not because she's a woman or anything
but I felt bad about that but I've
always compensated or taking a defensive
stance of well at least I'll clean like
hey I made a decision early on in our
marriage because I didn't know how to
cook and for whatever reasons which I
can go into if you want me to I've said
I'm just gonna take this and I'm gonna
be grateful and uncritical of anything
that you want to prepare because I know
that I would die if you didn't do it and
I will also then clean up so I think I
think I got a good track record I'm not
gonna say a great one because my wife's
partly listening but at least a decent
track record of at least compensated
with not cooking by cleaning you're also
like cleaning and I like cleaning I like
putting things away and a lot of people
who enjoy cooking they start to say and
Christy has said in the past and I've
heard chefs you know as I've spoken with
many chefs it's like the only part I
hate about cooking is the cleaning it's
like well let me take care of that Reza
as an as an offering of gratitude but
I'm but this guy doesn't either and I
find it interesting that the thing that
she's asking about is she's keying in on
the cooking part and maybe that's
because she likes the cleaning part so
I'll respect that but now I'm a little
out of my league because well let me ask
you so I'm just telling you buddy you
got he should do one or the other oh I
think maybe you can speak to this so
first of all it is interesting that you
don't cook right you know I think if you
were to analyze not personality but if
you were to analyze background you know
I was raised in a very traditional home
yeah where my mom did all the household
duties my dad couldn't cook anything
wouldn't cook anything he basically
grill a steak yeah he was the grill man
he was a grill man he'll grill a steak
he'll barbecue the chicken but it's
basically I don't know what it is about
baby boomer men but it's like I'm only
gonna cook if I'm outside in a moment
that good the moment that I come in is
like this isn't my territory you know
lots of reasons for that and so and my
mom did everything for us like my
brother
I never did laundry like we I think she
was just like you guys she didn't have
the patience for us to make the mistakes
that we would have made she was like
just let me do that you know and that's
kind of a baby boomer mom kind of thing
in a lot of ways so going into college I
never cooked anything but I like to eat
so much that there came a time in which
I was like I have to cook for myself it
wasn't like I want to be a cooker you
know it was like I want to cook so I can
eat and I love it
and in our dorm room there wasn't they
didn't we had one of those toaster oven
things and I don't recall using that
much not really cooking even if I were
to use it so then you're referring to
when we got our first apartment I had a
kitchen yeah and you started cooking
stuff yeah and also you know Greg had
Greg could cook a little bit
Tim could cook a little bit we all kind
of could cook a little bit but it was
like okay I'm gonna make Hamburger
Helper I'm gonna make a nice figure out
out of a box but you never you were like
I'll eat it but you never were like I'm
gonna make the hamburger help well I
know what fry up there camber right
there's the same it goes a little
something like this too many I mean
there's four guys live in an apartment
three of them are cooking in the kitchen
no but we here's the thing we were there
was also a laundry was in the kitchen we
would divide up there cooking would be
like tonight Greg is gonna make this or
tonight Tim is gonna make it tonight red
is gonna make it but there was never a
tonight link is gonna make it that never
worked into the mix but I find it
interesting we never talked about it I
didn't care I have no ill will about it
but you were actually on your own a lot
yeah being raised by a single mom and
being home alone a lot like you could
have cooked a lot of things you know
what so why didn't you I think maybe
that you got to get into this guy's head
I think that plays into it because I
think my mom because she had so many
demands on her life in you know feeding
me beans is one of them I think it was
like anything that was pre-made at the
grocery store we needed to get we needed
you know we she
the time or the energy to cook as much
so let's work with that theory because I
fact like everything in our house was
like you you pull off the foil top and
then you can just you eat it with a
spoon applesauce putting all the best
things all the best things and then bars
you can just open up and eat your cookie
but you didn't need bars for dinner I
mean she always cooked when I came over
she wouldn't she had that stovetop
skillet skillet thing like you stood on
the counter yeah yeah she she had her
like well you know talked about in the
book of mythicality she had her like few
meals yeah like she would like she's so
rotation yeah she had that she had the
rotation I don't know I I do maybe that
has something to do with it though was
that a lot of it was still like packaged
and I was I would be home alone for the
launches over the summer and I remember
my favorite thing was there was this
you'd peel the top off of this package
that would have roasted chicken legs
from like Holly farms or whatever it was
called roasted fully cooked chicken legs
and I wouldn't even heat him up I'll
just eat him cold okay it's like so easy
so it's like it's so easy it's so tasty
I was rewarded I mean I why go through
effort when all I got to do is rip this
the top off of this thing that's what I
learned is a child you just rip the top
off butter get to something else like
playing cards by yourself in your room
or looking at your GI Joes yeah I mean
to me so I think that when you think
about cooking you don't there is no joy
the joy of I cook I've never experienced
it ironically I mean when I took that
cooking class in Thailand I started I
was like I had this knife for a second I
was chopping stuff and like I actually
he made the meal and then we made it I
was like this is I could see how this
could be fun but it felt like an
entirely new experience to me like I
never experienced the fact of like
putting stuff together and and also
there's I think there's anxiety of like
having never done it it's like all I'm
gonna do is screw this up there's no way
that you're gonna work
yeah there's no way that's good there's
a lot of it's a lot of there's a lot of
steps there's a lot of things to get
right and if I'm gonna do it I got to do
it exactly right so maybe I think maybe
the coz cooking versus art versus baking
me you know but baking is more probably
your style because it's like all these
specific ingredients in specific
temperatures but it's too intimidating
to get into the exactness of that okay
but feel that so maybe this will help
with your your boyfriend because from my
perspective the reason I like doing it
and I don't do it that often I'll die
usually the weekends is when I have time
to like I've got time you know where I
get home probably 7 o'clock and so and
sometimes Jessica's home at the same
time and then we either do takeout or
we'll eat something late we don't we're
not one of those same as it eats at the
same time we eat somewhere between 6
o'clock and 9 o'clock and you never know
when it's gonna be but the the thing
that I like about it is I do like
building and creating things like I've
never done it but the idea of like
making a sculpture or you know painting
a painting like getting into something
like that that there's a process and
then there's a final product has always
been intriguing to me I think it's one
of the reasons I like what we do but the
beauty and cooking is that you get to do
the process and then you get to eat the
final product so it's better than art
because you get to eat it I love to eat
so much just one of my favorite paint a
painting and then heat it that would be
incredible so I so what you're getting
at for me and him cuz this is also you
got to find something you can connect
with in the process so I'm gonna find
the joy for yours the joy it's the art
of creation and then the art of
consuming the with the art of creation
and the exercise of consuming there is a
sense of accomplishment that I'm not
gonna make something that's as good as
what we can get
in Los Angeles most likely but I did it
man I'm eating the art that I made and
and so give back a child eating play-doh
back to her username science is an art
ironically maybe you know maybe we're
onto something that can help you tap
into his passion because I I you know
you you're a little divisive in the way
you've written this apparently spaghetti
is too complex for him you know you've
got a you got to lose the tude first of
all you know just because he doesn't
like doing cookie it's just like this
stuff you don't like doing don't you can
you're not gonna shame him in the
cooking but I think you can you can lure
him into it what's the best dish cuz I
my first thing baby - grilled cheese I
think it's you cooked stuff together
because you're Jesus a sandwich which is
easy but it's lightly cooked with every
step of cooking the grilled cheese you
take off an article of clothing you know
make it a little make it a bedroom make
it foreplay mix it up again I know you
can do this on either side of the
kitchen right which you always use the
same burner no use a different burner
there's the same right and this is how
it goes lovemaking starts in the kitchen
I agree with that okay so that's that's
another one one maybe art another one
maybe bribery I don't know it's like
I'll give you a Amazon gift card if you
learn how to make spaghetti I don't you
know again I'd that's well the specific
question was what's the most basic dish
I don't know I'm not putting a lot of
thought I don't think it's about how
basic the dishes it's not about the dish
being easy it's about tapping into
motivations yeah I I agree with that but
you got to you got to start somewhere
well I think I think that's the
secondary you can't you can't answer
that question you can't give them
grilled cheese until you've come to the
motivation because the motivation there
you gotta say you got a dress um oh it
needs to be it needs to be beef
stroganoff maybe just get a make a
painting and let him eat it and if
you're taking off your clothes you could
all that beef taken off
no clothes that's gonna make it a game
that's a good recipe you should do a
whole book we've take it off give me
another question but we're really
nailing them this morning
Mariah Boz L MC Boz L on Twitter I Drive
my friends crazy talking over them all
the time I just get so excited tips for
being a less obnoxious conversationalist
this is a little close to home what do
you mean well considering that not too
many pods ago we we talked about this
however you can't in fact it is stupid
for hunters to not wear orange are there
so many hunter let me get this out the
second thing is one time but I've seen
on my don't rain yeah cuz I let me just
finish the damn sentence man it's more
than one sentence it's multiple
sentences and my theory was you know I'm
not gonna do that joke where I interrupt
you because it's played out my theory
was that you interrupt me more than I
interrupt you and it got a little
prickly and in and then you what you
mate you gave an assignment no I just
said okay somebody make a compilation
and we actually talked to Kiki you're so
loud about this when we met her at
VidCon after she had she answered your
call she made a video that was a series
of you interrupting me and most of the
time saying sorry to interrupt when you
did it
it was not an exhaustive no elation
wasn't it you know I I think it was
funny that that that she that she
answered your call and it was all in
good fun and I've found it humorous but
listen I mean for that one she did some
kind of search there was something of a
search with like I don't interrupt him
and so what she did was I think all she
proved was that when
I interrupt you because I do I apologize
for it and I use the word I'm sorry for
interrupting so it's easier to like find
it in some sort of like okay in
description you don't apologize but you
do it just as much okay and this is
question might go huge question mark now
I'm not listen now don't get super
defensive I'm not okay I'm just gonna
keep breathing through my nose and I'm
not the man I am not mad about this
we've actually talked about this in the
in the past because first of all let's
have interrupted you I'm sorry for
interrupting you but I do I'm gonna have
a real conversation and I'm not gonna do
anything for comedic effect anymore from
this moment on okay we're having a real
real conversation sincere conversation
about interruption you took it I think
there's a couple of things we both like
to talk we both like to hear ourselves
talk this is a recipe for interruptions
I do it and you do it and I think that
who does it more does have something to
do with what it is that we're talking
about at the time if I get passionate
about something and I feel like I've got
a lot of important things to say about
it I will be more likely to interrupt
and I guess the same holds true for you
all that being said there is a
phenomenon and this is where the whole
apologizing about interrupting doesn't
really come into play and I don't really
know how often you do this in the
context of us just being on a podcast or
even on the show but this is the thing
we talked about before you interrupt a
lot and you don't know that you've
interrupted so you're not being rude on
purpose and to think the way that it
happens most often is we're in a
conversation either together or most
often in the context of a larger group
and we both begin talking it apart well
usually what happens is I start when
this particular thing happens I start
talking and I
get one two forwards out and then you
just start talking and then my
personality is pretty deferential in
those circumstances so I tend to stop
talking you don't even know that I
started talking it isn't like I don't
care about whatever it Rhett has to say
I'm gonna start talking
my theory is is that I can tell you way
that your brain kind of work to do that
yeah I think where it's better in like
meetings type of thing or like when
we're making decisions or processes of
light so it's not like shooting the
breeze
I think we're you're really talking
about when we're in like I'm not just
gonna say like a business conversation
but like a strategic or something that's
like there's a lot of moving parts I
tend to I think I I think it I think and
then speak about it a little slower so
like I'm I'll be a beat behind and then
but I'll be thinking intently informing
my thought and so someone may have
started talking but those two words that
you said I didn't hear because it was I
was still in the silence of about to
speak I would say it happens between 20
and 40 times a week I'm not exaggerating
now but it's just kind of become a part
of the way that we made it it's like in
the office kind of like in meetings I
think any group covers do you think it's
any shooting the breeze any any
conversation any group conversation so
there was a cup there couple years ago
intervention so there's no we've talked
about it before there was a couple years
ago where I made a decision that what I
was going to do when it happened was I
was just going to not stop talking
because I'm you know I know I'm gonna
trust me but I'm actually I'm a little
too nice in certain situations and so I
am very deferential like that my
personality is to be pretty differential
I'd like if there's two people walking
down the sidewalk
I'm gonna be the one who moves and says
excuse me right that's kind of I tend to
do that almost to a fault so my natural
disposition is
he started talking I'm gonna stop
talking so I tried to do a thing where I
would start saying something and then
you would start talking and I would just
talk a little bit louder and then it
just didn't work I don't remember you
doing that but I can only imagine that
that would just make me angry because
I'm like why is he talking why is he
yelling when I was talking welcome to
the club
but I I still cannot believe that if
you're saying I do this 20 to 40 times a
week I cannot believe that it's a fact I
cannot I mean I'm not exaggerating and
if so but I know that you don't know it
because you're not because I know that
you wouldn't do it intentionally so it
just kind of become a thing to don't
know what don't know that you would
started talking right yep but you'll
notice and you probably hear this from
me I would say a couple of times a month
especially if I fit I'll be like hold on
I'm talking you'll hear me say that
right hold on
I hold on a second I'm talking that's
when I feel like what I need to say
needs to be said right now most of the
time I'm like what I need to say can
probably be said after link finishes
saying what he's gonna say that's
typically what I do so my theory is that
it as it might translate into again it's
very different in this context because
I'm in your ear on a microphone I don't
think what we're talking now applies to
ear biscuits I don't think it does
either so I I do want to talk about that
which is what I thought we were gonna
talk about but we need to come up with a
plan for this because I I i cannot
believe this 20 to 40 times a week i
just can't believe it and if that's true
I want to know but there's got to be I
need a belt just notice there's gotta be
a this there's got to be a way that that
doesn't involve a bell how about you
wear a shot-caller oh no you can't start
making jokes we said we weren't making
ours this serie okay alright I'm just
saying there's got to be a gentle way
and a gentle and private way
for you to say all right you know what
it can't be private because there's
someone else in the conversation it
doesn't happen we're just talking to
each other it happens when the two of us
are talking to somebody else right it
happens but you do it you do it with
other people in the office as well but
they all do what I do they just stop
talking they stop talking because of the
boss is talking I stop talking because
I'm not willing to I honestly don't know
what's happening because you don't you
sure I already knew I already know it's
because of the way you was exactly what
you said like okay what she blamed is
you're not a rude person it is he didn't
he he was thinking about what he was
gonna say and you tend to not listen
when you're thinking about what you're
gonna say it's like you're not hearing
me speak but it's when there's a silence
and then it's like it's the kickoff of
the conversation so it's not like you've
been talking and talking and talking and
then all of a sudden I interrupt in the
middle again those are type of things
your business sometimes it might happen
with Mike there's a pause but the theory
is that and I was going to continue
there's if there's a pause and then it's
like oh now is a socially acceptable
opportunity for someone else potentially
me to speak so I'm going to speak but
I'm gonna need to formulate what I'm
gonna say because up and at this point
I've been listening I haven't been
formulating a thought it's like if it's
not that extreme but I think my I think
so linearly that or live my life so
linearly that maybe not in that extreme
but I do think that happens where it's
like I am listening and then there's a
pause but I don't know I haven't been
thinking about what I'm gonna say well
you've got two modes because you you
have a you're actually much more likely
to speak your thoughts to speak without
thinking that I am and that's a certain
mode and you tend to be in that mode and
when we're entertaining which I would
say this is entertainment hopefully but
and then also on the show but it doesn't
really happen in real but real-life
version of that is that I'm a verbal
processor so sometimes I don't know
exactly what I think about something
until I begin to speak it out so I don't
things definitively I say things
exploratory ly that's how I speak so
which I ironically would make you lead
you to believe that I could fill a gap
immediately because I don't know what
I'm gonna think it just it verbally
process it so those things don't work
till late together but I do think my
theory is because what I'm getting at
ultimately is some way that you can
gently flag that it's happening so that
I can be receptive to the feedback so
that I can get better about it if you're
right I but I believe you you're not
making this up but it's that hard for me
to believe that it happens forty times a
week four times a week would be eight
times a day I said 20 to 40 I would have
been fine with you know once or twice a
day this seems like a lot more than that
I think it depends on how many of those
conversations were in but anytime we're
in a one out of it how many
conversations if we have if we sit down
and have a meeting where we're both
speaking about something it is going to
have it okay I don't like that but I'm
saying but I do in my defense I do think
that if it's most likely to happen at a
point where there's a pause in the
conversation and then in that pause I'm
formulating something someone else
begins to speak but in my formulation I
still feel like I'm in the gap and then
I start talking a bit later because I do
know another thing that happens is we're
in a meeting and we've been asked to
give make a decision about something or
give creative feedback on something and
then you're like one or both of us will
give feedback then there'll be a pause
and then the person who's talking to us
like Stevie well then move on to the
next thing
and then halfway through her moving on
to the next thing I say one more thing
about the last thing because you you
still thinking about but when I realize
that you know that you're doing that and
I do that so sorry
before we move on and
do that a lot I would say you know that
I would say that if we're in a meeting
where there are seven items three of
those items are you're gonna have an
additional thought and and I actually
know and I'm here for her to just have a
twice as long pause or ask me do you
have anything else it's just not and
because that would be unusual in here
let me say I don't mind I actually it's
annoying like what you just said what
you that situation it's not even
annoying it's like that's how your brain
works and you are the kind of the
details guy and the second check and
that kind of thing and that's part of
our process so I welcome that it can be
a little it could sometimes it could be
like okay we just talked about that list
we got a bunch of other things I get it
so it could be a little annoying but
it's not really even the first thing
that we're talking about I would say
that I am so used to dealing with it
that it's only annoying to me if I'm
already like a little mad about
something at you and then I'm like okay
it's doing that thing but it's not
really it's kind of like this is just
the way he I know he doesn't know that
he's not interrupting me because he
doesn't think what I said he doesn't
know they'd interrupted me he doesn't
know that I started to speak and then he
started to speak so if you want to deal
with it I am open to you dealing with it
but I'm saying that you don't have to
deal with it because hey I don't know if
it's possible but you're saying I do it
to other people yeah but everybody I
think also I would say that most
everyone else also knows that you don't
maybe they don't know maybe they think
you just don't care what they have to
say but it's a good question I think
most people who get to know you
personally are like oh he's not okay
he's not being dismissive I just think
maybe he didn't hear me I think most
people would be smart who are here long
enough would well you think enough to
know you think I'm right that has had
the big beginning of conversations at
the end of gaps it is when yeah but that
gap could be someone is speaking and
they are there there was a pause and
they wanted to continue speaking but you
started talking and then they kept you
know you like so if I was saying
something
and I was making a point and then I said
it in the nest stop but then I started
going again and after but then you
started talking it does happen in that
situation but it is when you perceive a
gap you don't just interrupt people
willy-nilly it's you think there's a gap
or there it there is a gap whether it's
within a person's conversation or it's
in a group conversation and am i
contributing because here's the funny
thing it's like I actually observe in
other people in it I've been frustrated
by other people because who I think have
a tendency to when there's a gap in a
conversation they changed the subject
it's like oh they've been thinking about
what they wanted to say and when they
said it had nothing to do with what that
person was saying and then they just
started so they changed the subject to
whatever they wanted to talk about and
that that's something that I that urged
me
so I find it weird is that what I do
know okay because I do see you know when
I see the people who do that I'm like I
do not want to do that so okay so I
don't do that I'm changing the subject
and I've also noticing too whatever
we're talking about it but you're doing
it after someone else started speaking
the only issue is that in the context of
these conversations it is not unusual in
fact it's rather common for someone else
to begin speaking and then two to four
words after they start you start talking
that's that's it that's that that is the
that is explicitly what it is because I
also notice when other people if
somebody has a gap in their conversation
but they're in the middle of a point
that they haven't completely made and
then they give they start talking I that
does frustrate me because when I see
other people do that it's like well
they're not I I was following them and
they're not they haven't made their
point yet but you're saying I do that
well yeah there I think there definitely
are times when you're like but
it was obviously halfway done not fully
done what links started talking but what
you're doing is for whatever reason you
are not listening to that per ton on
tracking if you're tracking with
somebody you're tracking with somebody
yeah it's when you've made a decision
that you you're gonna say something
you're thinking and sometimes it'll be
like okay this person saying something
but you're thinking about what you're
gonna say because you're engaging with
it and so that point you're not little I
think is that you don't and this is
where I'm like I don't know I honestly
don't know you might need to just be I
don't know what you can do about it I
don't know if you you can't change your
any like your ability to listen while
you're thinking I need a plan if your
brain works in us hears we're gonna have
to look at examples so I need I need a
symbol I need like you just take your
take your fist and then put your pinkie
up and put it over your right nipple
that's and then I'll know I'll know that
I did it and then I'll say okay why did
I do that that's why I did it and I'll
be able to explain it to myself and to
you and and if I need to change
something I can but I'm gonna need that
feedback I think maybe we and it's gonna
need to be of I think maybe there should
just be a word and it can't be like how
you just did it red light you can't but
there's other people in the room you
can't just be like if I I just don't
I want to equip you so that I'm
receptive to this I don't know what it's
gonna be because if you I'm gonna
interrupt somebody and then you're gonna
interrupt me for interrupting them and
what tell them to go ahead no I just
need it it needs to be a physical symbol
well do you think it needs to happen in
the moment or do you think after the
conversation is over I can be like well
let me tell you that there's a couple of
times that you did that thing when I was
saying this or when Stevie was saying
that what do you think would be more
helpful if it's right after this because
I want to be I want to assure you is
that be right I'm not doing this for me
I've got if I'm doing this for you if
you want it to be done because I don't
think I know you were gonna do this when
we're talking about it because I said an
intervention
I didn't know I was gonna talk about it
until I saw the question I wasn't like I
need to talk to link about this because
we kind of talked about this a few years
ago but we were talking about you know
we we tended like this is one of the
keys to our friendship I think we check
in with each other is you know it's like
that's why we were in a relation what
what did we decide when we checked you
told we were talking about a lot of
different things and I think I just
threw in there and you always interrupt
me I don't I don't think that it was
constructive but we've been pretty
successful in friendship and in business
with this phenomenon existing and so I'm
not angry about it I'm just saying that
this is so don't I don't feel like
you're angry about it I feel but I do
think it's an interesting that maybe
other people are because they I know you
so well that I know that you're not
actually interrupting me but maybe other
people are like you interrupt me all the
time I don't know
now I'm gonna schedule meetings with
every employee and I'm gonna ask him now
there are times when I intentionally
interrupt people in a meeting when I
feel like we need to move on or I get
what you're saying or so there are there
are times when I exercise you know that
the position of well I can dictate the
pace of this conversation because this
meetings for me and when you do that you
acknowledge that you're doing it so I
don't think that's an issue right so
it's like I'm not gonna but I don't want
a lesson I don't want people to think
I'm doing it when I'm not that's just
it's disturbing to find out that you've
done something apparently 20 to 40 times
that you don't eat your bolivia stew so
that's it's just disturbing and I like
to you know so I your yes did you
suggest putting up the pinky no no that
was me after every meeting I'm gonna say
did it happen tell me when it happened
my thing you have to know well my tea
is that and I'm does that work yeah my
theory is that at least initially you're
gonna go into conversations in the next
in the coming days and weeks thinking
about this and so it's probably gonna be
you it may go away completely for a
period of time when it comes back I'll
let you know it comes if it comes back
if it comes back I I can have hope then
I'll let you know but it may it may not
it may not happen when you're just going
into it with like I'm kind of I know
that this thing happens I didn't realize
it happen but I'm now I'm thinking about
it just an awareness could be all that
you need okay now to shift over in you
know in the interest of rapid over this
conversation yeah but I do want to shift
over to the ear biscuits dynamic which I
think nothing that we talked about
applies because we're in a performance
mode when we're both talking and I do
acknowledge that there has there is an
element of the way that there are times
when I'll interrupt that I thought was
more part of the way that this show
worked that interrupting each other was
part of it that then through like the
feedback of listeners I'm like hmm it's
actually having an annoying effect or a
frustrating effect like if you're in the
middle of something that you're really
passionate about there was a point in
the past not currently in my mind where
I thought that my my role in the
entertainment quotient of the
conversation was to to quip and
interject and sometimes just to throw in
some things when you were going on a
monologue and then I think I expected
you to do the same thing now I may not
have reacted in a positive way to it
because I may not have been capable of
staying on task in my monologue when if
you were to do it to me some and maybe
you I'm throwing out theories here maybe
you knew that so you didn't do it but if
you were to have asked me I would have
described the conversation climate of
ear biscuits to be that we are both
constantly interrupting each other and
it's like there's kind of a barrage of
those things and like in the middle of a
passionate point we may go off on this
big long rabbit trail because somebody
said something we may get in an argument
or have a laugh attack or like go way
off and then we come back eventually and
that's kind of entertainment mode of
what your biscuits is I think we both do
that I think we do it in different ways
and I think this is why it's Percy I
think there's two factors this is again
this is theoretical but I've also the
second half of my point was I've changed
my mind about that okay okay well okay
so I'm saying that's how I did think but
then just to get my complete point out
there people were annoyed by me and
erupting and so I am making a conscious
effort over the past few months of doing
it less like I would I've been I've
literally tried to put my hand over my
mouth okay rets making a point he cares
about this it would be frustrating if I
kept interrupting it wouldn't be
entertaining for some reason I thought
it was but it's not so I'm gonna just so
I've actually I've been trying to
interrupt less I can say I have noticed
that no I but I don't think that your
instincts were wrong I think that we
interrupts in different ways and I think
that again neither one of us have ever
taken an improv class right but
obviously the the yes--and principle is
something that is true to improv and I
think that as we have a lot of chemistry
we have a lot of comedic chemistry but
your disposition is not yes aunt
it just isn't yes and that's not there's
nothing about link Neal that is yes and
there's a lot of but what or yeah yeah
and and and or totally and so our
left-field you bring
and whereas you might be telling a story
and I'm and you'll notice that the way
that I kind of interject into a story
that you're telling is I'm like yep
mm-hmm
or little joke here in a certain tone
and again and I think it has something
to do with like being raised in a bigger
family where people were telling stories
and you're interjecting and that kind of
thing and you tend to do the same thing
but when you do it it has its more dear
ailing than add then then yes and kind
of thing so again it's part of who you
are I haven't it may be annoying to an
audience member at times it's not
personally annoying to me yeah I'm
talking about them I think the feedback
has been helpful of this like if you're
if you're making a point and you're
obviously getting at something and I I'm
engaged I know what you're getting at
but I feel like what normally could take
eight minutes it would be better if it
took 16 minutes because in the that
additional 8 minutes of something
unexpected or fill in the blank it's it
just adds to the entertainment factor
but now I understand that like an 8
minute story that you gotta wait an
additional 8 minutes to get to the point
it's also it's frustrating so and so
there's a middle ground of like if
you're gonna add a minute of energetic
congestion because it is after all a
conversation it's not a series of hand
off monologues but I do think that there
was there was an era of my ways in them
in that mindset well and I would say
that your capacity to let me talk
uninterrupted is lower than my capacity
for you to talk uninterrupted but I
think that's a personality thing and I
don't you know I'm saying I did I just
think that I can kind of like if you
spoke for four minutes without me saying
anything there's certain times where
I'll just kind of settle in and I'm like
this is I'm not now listen let me be
very clear I like to hear myself talk
I probably perceived as more of an
[ __ ] than you are to most people so
I'm not trying to I'm not defending
myself I'm just saying in there certain
aspects about the way that that Congress
does conversations come out that it
might be like okay link sent tell this
story if I say anything is going to be
very it's not it's not going to be D
railing it's gonna be a little bit
additive it's not gonna be a different
perspective it's gonna be like an
agreement or look it's good or it's not
gonna be nothing and I just don't think
that's your disposition I think your
disposition is if I'm gonna say
something it's gonna be like the
ping-pong ball came to my side of the
table for a second so whereas I might
enter into more of a hype man sort of
interaction you enter into the ball was
just volleyed to me let me say something
that's a little more substantial and
probably a little weird again I think
that's what people like about your style
of comedy but I think that it's it's
interesting when you apply it to
different types of conversations because
I think that if if you're telling we
both like to tell stories from things
that have happened to us and I'm not
really interested in like who does more
of that or whatever but I because I
don't know or care but I think when it
comes to talking about ideas or things
that aren't like personal experience
type thing like you'll get on these
points about that and I feel like you're
in more of you that's more of your zone
than my zone and so I do think there's
an interesting interplay with how we
discuss those type of things that like
sometimes it's not like okay you're
making a point I'm making a counterpoint
back and forth I think it's more of like
I'm gonna I'm gonna introduce same way
that you are so it's and so I think that
there's more opportunity for me to have
interruptions that couldn't work in that
setting versus when it's like a story
that we're telling I don't think that I
would like the thing I don't do that to
you
when it's like Oh like I'm hearing a
tale here this is happening there's a
beginning middle and end so to speak
it's not an opening a conversation
whereas you feel like you're you're
you're moving towards this point or this
conclusion but I'm feeling like we're
having an open-ended conversation and I
think in that dynamic it has led to a
frustration for the for the listener
well and I think and I do get it's a
matter of fact I was I don't know how I
got here but I was looking at the
comments on our appearance on eight the
h3 h3 podcast which is over a year ago
mm-hmm and the nature of the questions
that Ethan was asking were very much
about like sort of like theoretical
things about the YouTube platform and
stuff that just immediately like I have
all these thoughts about right yeah and
people are like Rhett is interrupting
link a bunch and so it did the the very
beginning of this was I think it depends
on the mode of conversation whether
somebody whether you would be like well
red is interrupting link or link is
interrupting Rhett because I don't I
don't think this is a one-way thing I
think that it just kind of depends on
the nature of what it is that's being
discussed and who's more passionate
about it
and so in terms of the in the context of
ear biscuits I also don't feel like in
those this is where it's like there's a
point that you want to make if if I do
interject you can get frustrated because
you're trying to make a point whereas
when I talk about those same things i
verbally process it more so I don't
necessarily know the exact point I'm
making I'm putting it out there for like
having heard it and discussed it for us
to reach a conclusion together and I
think that's that's the different way we
approach it so I actually don't feel I
don't think I feel it's sensitive to
being interrupted when we're talking
about ideas as you do but as opposed to
when
a story so I might be more sensitive to
interrupting during a story than I am
when I'm interrupting during an idea
conversation yeah um well this has
become an interesting conversation from
your question from Mariah's question
tips for being a less obnoxious
conversationalist just talk it out we
turned a lot of these this is again this
is one of the reasons that we enter
interrupt each other is we turn these
questions into just conversation
dividers we're both yes so obnoxious
we're both mildly narcissistic you kind
of have to be in this business but we I
don't think I'm narcissistic well we but
we took we took the narcissism quiz
remember on the show and we both got the
same score I don't know I think I'm a
psychopath
no that's the smell but we were there
there's a narcissism self evaluation
that scores you on a scale like 1 to 30
or whatever and it puts different
professions in different places
leave it to anarse this is to take a
self-evaluation test and and we what we
did it on that we did it for the show
and we both scored I don't know I can't
remember the exact number but it was
like a 14 or whatever which is higher
than a general population so more
narcissistic than the general population
and you in the in sort of the celebrity
entertainer range we were in the
celebrity entertainer range which is no
surprise this town is full of
self-obsessed people that's what makes
Hollywood Hollyweird right but we got a
little bit of that that kind of got us
into what we do but hopefully not so
much that we're not able to step back
and evaluate it for the narcissistic
that we can't be I maybe we helped maybe
maybe us making it about ourselves
helped at least it's just take it for
what it mean I had fun talking about you
and me stirred up in you know
let's see how it goes and I'm gonna be
sleeping on the other side of the bed
this is not gonna make me have that much
changel it's not gonna be a good way to
change one thing at a time all right do
you have a wreck I have a quick wreck
this is a little unusual it's a product
that is not a sponsor but I am making an
effort to do less meat based and animal
based products in in my life and in my
food not cutting them out completely but
you know the environment just well you
know it's there's all there's only good
reasons for it right environment greater
ethical reasons all that but one of the
ways that I've incorporated that is into
these cook speaking of cooking I'd make
these scrambles a lot of times on
Saturday morning with a lot of the
things that we've got in the fridge so
you got eggs and cheese and some kind of
meat and then mushrooms or onions or
whatever we got right put some hot sauce
in it put it in a burrito it's good well
my friend I like it my kids are too
picky so they eat something else but I'm
slowly moving towards a place where that
entire scramble even down to the eggs is
not animal-based and one of the steps
towards that was the cheese and this is
a big thing for me was substituting
vegan cheese which I've tried multiple
times which is nuts
I'm like literally literally nuts but I
have found what I think is a pretty good
cheese that I've tried on a burger as a
slice and also put the shreds in my
scramble daya da iya it's like one of
the most popular ones that you'll see
when you go to this section in the
grocery store but I tried it a couple
years ago and I didn't like it I don't
know if my tastes have change but I
think they've actually reformulated it
it's getting pretty good it's not real
cheese is it pricy uh probably but you
don't even look at but if you if if you
don't eat it
next to regular cheese don't do that
don't don't make that mistake
idiot just put it into something that
would normally have cheese there's a
bunch of different flavors
bunch of different presentations where
they're shredded or blocks or slices
daya da y da iya I recommend you try it
not a sponsor maybe will be maybe maybe
what would like to be a sponsor I would
like them to be a sponsor daya if you're
listening hash tag ear biscuits let us
know what you think about this you weigh
in on the on the interruption thing I
think that's gonna generate a lot of
conversation hell we may have to title
at that
Kieko probably probably so alright we're
up for it thank you for hanging out and
we'll speak at you next week to watch
more ear biscuits click on the playlist
on the right to watch the previous
episode of your biscuits click on the
playlist to the left and don't forget to
click on the circular icon to subscribe
if you prefer to listen to this podcast
it's available on all your favorite
podcast platforms thanks for being your
mythical best
[Music]